My favorite thing about this tartlet tubing mascara
is that it comes off.
I thought it was super magical because it's like you put on a coat
and then it kind of sticks to itself
so it'll give you length.
It's that it actually comes off.
It's not, you know,
with typical mascara.
I don't always fucking wash my face before I go to bed.
Or even if I do,
I can't always get the mascara all the way off.
So then I wake up, and then I already have, like,
black shit smeared under my eyes.
I know you've seen my other Tik Toks,
and I hate it.
This shit just comes off.
It flakes off. At my daughter was like, hello,
this tartlet tubing mascara is super, duper,
duper worth it.
And the stay away.
It comes in the trio of their best sellers.
And I get why they're the best sellers.
Super worth it. And link right here.